ils sont partout là où on s'y attend le
moins dans nos aliments il ya un
antimicrobien le propionate de questions
a pas vraiment modifié
pourquoi quand les industries font les
mêmes plats que l'on fait la maison et
ajoutent-ils de nombreuses des tifs
la plupart des additifs là qu'on va voir
sur les étiquettes on voit beaucoup
quand même des gens qui voient une
texture ans qui va s'assurer par exemple
qui sont un gâteau que la crise va pas
sa fin et c'est avec le temps qui va
rester beau c'est tous des agents qui
vont être texturants qui vont aider la
l'immense conserver plus longtemps mais
pas au point de vue de la microbiologie
l'a vraiment point de vue de quand tu
arrives à l'épicerie et le gâteau géant
d'are encore bon petit goût de lâcheté
qui vont avoir les agents de
conservation surtout pour les produits
réfrigérés qui vont inhiber les micros
gagner cette erreur généralement les
aliments tablettes beaucoup d'agents de
conservation passé non périssables des
concerts de tété raul congélateurs ont
plutôt proposé un agent de conservation
c'est vraiment tout ce qui est au frigo
qu'on va avoir des agents qui vont tuer
les bactéries qui vont les empêcher de
se multiplient
quand on voit les additifs dans un
produit congelé c'est pourquoi ben en
fait l'utilisation de sel c'est pour les
veaux technologique dans ce qu'on veut
c'est que l'aliment soit boas qui vaut
décongeler donc qui reste quand même
c'est qu'ils soient pas trop humide donc
est vraiment là à voir une bonne texture
comme si on venait de le faire à la
maison comme les pizzas congelées y la
difficulté aussi avec les pizzas comme
ce prêt fait congeler sais que tu vas
voir la source qui liquide au dessus
d'une part avec le nouveau portable
après l'humidité de la sauce dont claude
soumettre des gommes désaffection pour
ta part tu sors pas trop humide casting
moi je trouve que la partie quand c'est
quand même beaucoup d'agents faire que
pour donner une bonne texture à la pâte
élasticité des gommes il va voir aussi
entre autres le des enzymes qu'on va
utiliser dans la part d'un truc à millas
aussi tout à fait inoffensif fin 2011 on
en a dans notre salle et il en a j'en
revends
mon dieu aujourd'hui les gens ont plus
peur aux additifs que jadis pourquoi
c'est une bonne question il ya
l'argument de caen le nom et chimiques
puis qu'on ne connaît pas faudrait pas
manger les aliments le mois en tant que
chien c'est quelque chose qui fait
dresser les poils on s'entend que c'est
pas parce qu'on connaît pas la cdas
corbeil que ces chenilles pascal corbex
la vitamine c erie torbat de sodium
savez dérivés d'aspe scorbé l'acide
citrique saviez du jus de citron factea
pour ben gray dhien à nos aliments qui
sont là et qui proviennent de fruits de
légumes et qu'ils ont au chimique dans
un taxi de le composé actif d'un aliment
convoi utilisé pour faire des
formulations
on a concocté par nos chefs dessous pour
poivrons rouges grillés et fromages
gouda
souvent les additifs sont ajoutés pour
faire vendre la plupart de ces agents de
conservation sont là pour et mystifiant
stabilisant donc tu vois que à
l'intérieur les choses sont en
suspension c'est vrai ce départ et donc
l'euro les agents ne je pense qu'à tout
simple que j'ai vu dans la liste seule
leur rôle c'est vraiment de s'assurer
que la soupe c'est parfois puis tout
récent ni munitions à l'intérieur si tu
rates de sodium phosphates de sodium
rebond de la veille
oui exactement excellent puis ensuite me
donne maïs modifié la donne ouais
effectivement lui aussi pour avoir le
rôle de textures ans dont l'amidon
c'est le suc on vous retrouver dans des
seriacom par exemple blé riz le maïs
donc c'est une très grosse molécule de
sucre
on retrouve aussi des émulsifiants danse
et vinaigrette
donc c'est déstabilisant qui vont être à
l'intérieur qu'ils vont regarder
l'émission en place ici on n'a pas ça
c'est pour ceux que la vinaigrette se
séparent c'est vraiment dur de se
départir de jason de conservation même
en faisant maison d animal parce que la
crème qu'on va utiliser pour faire notre
boulot mais c'est la même crainte qu'on
utilise dans l'industrie cette crème loi
contient des agents texture ans dont dix
ça revient pas mal ou même à moi de par
notre propre page dans notre corps qui
permet de faire notre propre crème ça il
faut se rappeler que tout les additifs
qui sont autorisés au canada sont
approuvés par santé canada à la barre
vous industrie peut pas obliger dans le
club ont des attitudes prendre ceux qui
veulent
plus de 95% d éditer photo risée sont
les mêmes en europe et en amérique du
nord par contre des recherches récentes
pointent du doigt certains d'entre eux
qui auraient de potentiels effets
négatifs sur la santé comme certains
colorants qui pourrait provoquer de
l'hyperactivité chez les enfants
dioxyde de titane jours de soleil fcf
tartrazine on en a deux choléra petite
ava qu'à traverser la rue
mais justement on va mettre ces
colorants l'introduction des titans ce
n'est une couleur demain qui est assez
opaque ça va rendre la pareille avec une
belle texte une belle couleur
intéressante puis le jour ni cerné par
la tartrazine donc d'un jour de plus
éclatant
et attention on cache parfois des
ingrédients controversé
là les industriels sont obligés de faire
des substitutions par exemple dans les
charcuteries on a remplacé le nitrite
par de la pâte de céleri personnellement
le sutsas et trompeurs la com com
pratique parce que la peau de céleri
c'est tout simplement d'un pot de
servier qui contient des nitrates qui va
être fermentés par des bactéries qui
vont les transforme en nitrites donc à
la fin c'est une peau de nitrites qui
est un peu controversé qui a un
potentiel cancérogène justement à cause
des nitrosamines qui peuvent se former
dans la viande
alors morale de l'histoire idéalement on
fait nous même où on cherche des
produits avec une courte liste
d'ingrédients mais surtout on examine le
tableau de la valeur nutritive jeu se
regarder ça c'est déjà un très beau vous
pour s'affronter puis c'est un peu plus
simple aussi parce que c'est vraiment
difficile de retenir le tout les
additifs fait savoir lui devant lui du
moins bon sur facebook pression
m